my wife law she's sick so it's the lungs
Dean acting right the funniest outtake
ever - how thick I think we've ever ever
ever produced from the hodgetwins yes
mr. YouTube sir
I mean it's this new YouTube changed
with the Aukerman and and every time you
change me
that's what you've been telling us and
my wife it's the holidays so she's sick
it's a long habit and the algorithm is
kuppa guys and it's the holidays so my
wife Laura she's sick it's okay
my wife law she's sick so it's the lungs
Dean acting right
just love a safe is the word they melt
director mixtape it's my wife she's sick
it's her lungs be nekked and right so
she can't breathe but oh well laughing
it just pigs more man okay okay
my wife Lord she's sick
it's a long staying acting right breathe
I just came laughing okay come on Cooper
going into you and it's my wife sir
she's sick it's the lungs
Danette them right so
[Music]
do forgive a long I it's the holiday sir
my wife Lord she's sick
it's of lungs deigned acting right sir
the [ __ ] came breathe God bet it's my
wife Lord she's sick it's the lungs
Dean acting right sir the [ __ ] can't
breathe
could you just please explain to me the
new policy sir
so you know suicune better living again
sir
[Laughter]
no no mr. YouTube you know all you had
was a bunch of cat videos just want an
opportunity to live for my family for my
wife Lord but you told mommy we did
anything he told us to we've need to do
two workshops and pay for it you know
he's he's right sir we we used all the
hard on dollars understood I had he had
jobs for word man you you know what sir
he's right sir mr. perfect
he's right sir oh we don't know my
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
like this video subscribe hit the
notification bell or if you want to
continue to enjoy free content support
us at ladder with credit.com /mo club
where you get the full nightly show an
hour everyday free along with all of our
friends content if not you don't want to
do any of those things you're probably
just here you're watching me seething
you came here to hate watch that being
said the internet was created for people
like you